THAT'S A QUESTION THAT WE,
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, YOU,
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, DESERVE
TO KNOW THE ANSWER TO.
ALL RIGHT, HERE WITH
REACTION, SO MANY QUESTIONS
TONIGHT, FORMER DEPUTY
ASSISTANT TO THE PRESIDENT
BOB SNOOZE, NATIONAL
SECURITY STRATEGIST
DR. SEBASTIAN GORKA AND
FORMER FBI ASSISTANT
DIRECTOR JAMES.
JAMES, I HAVE KNOWN YOU A
LOT OF YEARS.
I HAVE NOTHING BUT THE
DEEPEST RESPECT FOR ALL LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
THEY RISK THEIR LIVES.
THEY KEEP OUR COUNTRY SAFE.
THEY DO IT BECAUSE THEY LOVE
THEIR COUNTRY.
AS A FORMER TOP FBI GUY
YOU'RE WATCHING ALL OF THIS.
WHAT ARE YOUR GENERAL
THOUGHTS.
>> WELL, A AGREE WITH WHAT
YOU JUST SAID, SEAN, YEAH,
WE HAVE KNOWN EACH OTHER FOR
A LONG TIME AND WE BOTH
RESPECT -- I CERTAINLY
RESPECT MY 27 YEARS AND THE
PEOPLE I WORKED WITH YES WE
DID RISK OUR LIVES FROM TIME
TO TIME.
WE CAME TO WORK EVERY
MORNING BECAUSE IT WAS THE
RIGHT THING TO DO TO PROTECT
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ON A
WHOLE HOST OF JURISDICTION
THAT THE BUREAU HAD AND ALSO
WORKING WITH THE STATE AND
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT.
YOU KNOW, I HAVE BEEN
EXTREMELY, EXTREMELY UPSET
ABOUT THIS.
I MEAN A YEAR AND A HALF AGO
I STARTED, YOU KNOW, I
STARTED WATCHING ABOUT WHAT
JIM COMEY WAS DOING AND IT
MADE NO SENSE.
YOU KNOW, WHAT HE WAS
TALKING ABOUT WAS WAY OUST
THE BOUNDARIES OF WHAT THE
FBI ACTUALLY DOES.
THE PROCEDURES THE FBI GOES
THROUGH ON INVESTIGATIONS.
AND IT WAS CLEAR TO ME THAT
HE WAS PLAYING WITH A
DIFFERENT DRUMMER, LET ME
TELL YOU THAT.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU,
TOO.
>> GO AHEAD.
>> Sean: IN ALL YOUR YEARS
IN THE FBI DID YOU EVER HERE
OF AN EXONERATION MONTHS
BEFORE THE PRINCIPLE, SOME
18 OF THEM, INCLUDING THE
MAIN PRINCIPLE, IS EVER
INTERVIEWED?
DID YOU EVER HEAR OF A FISA
COURT BEING HANDED
INFORMATION THAT THEY KNOW
IS POLITICAL AND WHO PAID
FOR IT AND NOT TELLING THE
FISA JUDGE AND NOT VERIFYING
IT?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
I MEAN, THAT JUST NEVER TOOK
PLACE.
I WAS INVOLVED WITH
NUMEROUS, NUMEROUS FISA
ORDERS WHEN I WAS THE HEAD
OF THE FBI IN NEW YORK AND
WHEN I WAS AN AGENT.
AND THIS JUST DOESN'T
HAPPEN.
AND NEVER HAPPENED.
AND IT'S PATHETIC.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT A SMALL
NUMBER OF PEOPLE.
COMEY BROUGHT IN SYCOPHANTS
AND PUT THEM ON THE FLOOR OF
THE HOOVER BUILDING AND TOOK
THE INVESTIGATIONS OUT OF
THE FIELD OFFICES IN NEW
YORK AND LITTLE ROCK AND
OTHER PLACES.
AND THEY CONDUCTED THIS SHAM
INVESTIGATION.
AND COMEYS OF COURSE IT WAS.
IN WAS HE NOT SMART ENOUGH
TO KNOW WHEN HE WAS DANCING
WITH THE DEVIL THE MUSIC WAS
GOING TO STOP SOME DAY.
AND IT DID.
AND HE HAD THAT PATHETIC
PRESS CONFERENCE THAT WAS SO
FAR OUT OF OUT OF BOUNDS.
AND THEN, OF COURSE, ALL
THAT WE KNOW NOW SINCE THEN
JUST PATHETIC.
>> Sean: DR. GORKA, WE GOT
THIS NEW INFORMATION PAUL
OFFICER J TONIGHT WHICH I
THINK IS FASCINATING.
COMMENT ON BRENNAN, CLAPPER,
AND SUSAN RICE'S EMAIL BUT,
REMEMBER, WE HAVEN'T GOTTEN
TO THE BOTTOM OF THE
SURVEILLANCE, THE UNMASKING,
THE LACK OF MINUTE
THE LACK MF MINUTE
THE LACK MINMINUTE
THE LACK MINIMNUTE
THE LACK MINIMUMTE
THE LACK MINIMUMMIZATION.
SOMEBODY THAT SERVED OUR
COUNTRY FOR 30 SOME ODD
YEARS OF HIS LIFE.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THESE
NEW DEVELOPMENTS.
>> FINALLY WE'RE GETTING TO
FIND WHO IS BEHIND THE
CURTAIN.
AND IT'S GOING TO THE VERY,
VERY TOP OF THE LAST
ADMINISTRATION.
WE HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
FISA GATE OR MEMO GATE.
WE WILL PROBABLY END UP
TALKING ABOUT OBAMA GATE.
LOOK AT THE FACT ALREADY.
I MEAN JOHN BRENNAN, JUST
GOOGLE WHO THIS PERSON IS
JOHN BRENNAN IN 1976 VOTED
FOR GUS HALL, THE COMMUNIST
PARTY CANDIDATE FOR AMERICAN
PRESIDENT AND THEN HE JOINS
THE CIA FOUR YEARS LATER AND
THEN OBAMA EVENTUALLY MAKES
HIM DIRECTOR OF THE CIA.
A MAN WHO VOTED FOR THE
COMMUNIST PARTY TO TAKE OVER
AMERICA?
LOOK AT SUSAN RICE.
THIS.
>> Sean: I HAVE NEVER HEARD
THAT BY THE WAY.
THAT'S NEWS TO ME.
WE WILL DIG DEEPER.
>> IT'S ON CNN.
CAN YOU GOOGLE IT.
>> Sean: FAKE NEWS CNN IT'S
GOT TO BE TRUE.
>> NO, NO.
>> IT IS TRUE.
>> WASHINGTON EXAMINER AND
CNN.
HE GOT IN TROUBLE BECAUSE HE
DIDN'T KNOW IF HE WAS GOING
TO PASS HIS POLYGRAPH IN
1908 WHEN HE JOINED THE CIA.
THESE ARE THE KIND OF PEOPLE
WHO RAN THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
AND LET ME --
>> Sean: WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF
SUSAN RICE THEN?
THAT'S THE BIGGEST CYA I
HAVE EVER SEEN IN MY LIFE.
>> LOOK AT THE ARROGANCE OF
IT IT'S NOT EVEN SUBTLE.
IT'S STRAIGHT OUT OF
SHAKESPEARE THE LADY DOTH
PROTEST TOO MUCH.
WHEN YOU HAVE SENT EMAIL TO
YOUR COLLEAGUES IN YOUR
WHOLE CAREER BY THE WAY MAKE
SURE WE DO EVERYTHING
LEGALLY JUST LIKE WE HAVE
BEEN DOING, WINK, WINK, YOU
KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
>> Sean: LAST WORD, JIM.
>> JUST ONE THING.
THE UNMASKING PART OF ALL
OF, THIS THAT'S "THE BIG
STORY."  THE U.N. AMBASSADOR
SAMANTHA POWER, 260.
>> Sean: 300.
>> AT LEAST 260 UNMASKING
REQUESTS, WHY?
>> Sean: IN A YEAR.
>> UNMASKING AMERICANS?
WHY?
THAT'S "THE BIG STORY."
>> Sean: WE WILL GET TO THAT
TOO.
>> I AGREE SEBASTIAN,
ABSOLUTELY.
JUST THE TIP OF THE ICE BEG
HAVE YOU MENTIONED FOR
MONTHS NOW THIS UNMASK
SOMETHING GOING TO BE A HUGE
THING, URANIUM ONE.
YOU KNOW, EVEN BENGHAZI.
I MEAN, OBAMA BASICALLY
TURNED LOOSE THE SYCOPHANTS
IN THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY AND OTHERS REALLY
TO CONDUCT ALL THIS
FRAUDULENT CRAP AROUND THE
ELECTION TO TRY TO NOT HAVE
TRUMP BE ELECTED AND, OF
COURSE, IT CONTINUES TO THIS
DAY THIS PHONY RUSSIAN
INVESTIGATION.
>> Sean: I HAVE GOT TO RUN.
ONE OF THE REASONS WE ARE
GETTING TO THE TRUTH AND I
THINK OUR AUDIENCE NEEDS TO
KNOW THIS BECAUSE THERE ARE
GOOD AND HONORABLE PEOPLE,
MOST OF THEM, THE VAST
MAJORITY, THE 99% AND THE
FBI AND THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY.
THEY ARE FED UP WITH THIS.